following the release of the House
Intelligence Committee memo on Friday
Donald Trump jr. said the memo was quote
a piece of sweet revenge for his family
and proved that the entire Russia
investigation is built on a foundation
of sand Donald Trump jr. joins us
tonight thanks coming up
hey you don't Duggar doing great so what
was your reaction to the memo what do
you think the takeaway is well listen I
I think the takeaway should that be that
Americans should be a little bit scared
about what's going on right now I mean
when you hear this stuff going on you
don't think of this happening in the
United States you don't think of this
happening in the country where we have a
foundation of laws and principles
grounded in the Constitution because
this to me seems like a clear violation
of that you have a court that virtually
no one knows anything about just
haphazardly granting full surveillance
of American citizens in this case the
duly elected future President of the
United States based on shady information
paid for by the opposition party's
candidate in that presidential race I
mean this is crazy stuff
it does seem outside the bounds of what
the law was written to allow and yet it
is allowed under the law and that law
was just reauthorized by the
republican-controlled Congress with very
little debate why do you think that was
you know I don't know but I think they
probably want to revisit that after
seeing all of this I mean a lots changed
since we last spoke about this basically
ten days ago and that had happened just
before this but I think you know as an
American citizen to see this stuff going
on to try to subvert democracy this way
based on these characters and these
people who are so biased and splay
greatly so that is scary I mean it's one
thing if you're doing it in a sort of
bipartisan system but that's not at all
what we have here so this all the things
that we're talking about were committed
by allegedly committed by employees of
the executive branch which is now the
Trump executive branch yes so what's
what's the solution going forward how do
you fix this you know I don't know I
think we have to open everything up you
know listen to the Democratic memo I'm
sure that'll be a winner given that
Schiff is doing this and everything he's
been spreading for a long time but you
can see the fear in their eyes because
the one thing is we've always been in a
very one-sided battle right because the
Republicans can have their talking
points and there is bias there obviously
as well but when you have the mainstream
media so willing to sell for the other
side so willing to go to battle for
anything the other side says so willing
to take whatever they say and just say
you know what that is the gospel there's
nothing else that could contest what
this person is saying that's where it
starts to get scary to me so I say open
it all up but let's see the FISA Court
transcripts
let's see everything that went into this
because I think once all of that comes
out not just the rebuttal that they've
had weeks to be able to say this is how
we're gonna counter it but let's see
those court transcripts because I want
to know what that judge saw when they
reauthorized it all this stuff was based
on Carter page and yet it was
reauthorized numerous times after Carter
page was not even a part of the campaign
anymore
so what is their basis for the ongoing
investigation so the rebuttal memo that
you just referred to the shift memo the
House Intelligence Committee has voted
to declassify it that's going to the
president presumably we'll all get to
see it soon and the media will applaud
its declassification they didn't they
will run but they did not applaud the
declassification of the Nunez memo no
was it striking to you to see reporters
argue for more secrecy that the public
doesn't have a right to know
I had a field day with that one on my
social media accounts because it was the
first time in history where I'm watching
the media effectively argue for less
information and you know touting the
talking point this is gonna make it
really difficult to investigate people
we're gonna be giving up trade secrets
people I didn't see any of that in the
memo I didn't see a thing but those were
the shift' talking points to try to
prevent it from ever coming out and the
media was more than willing to carry his
bags to make sure that everyone knew
that those things were gonna happen and
the sky was falling
if this memo was released huh but none
of the people calling for it remain
classified in the press had seen the
memo so well but you know who knows what
they knew what they had seen what had be
given I mean it's not like there hasn't
been leaks like a sieve from various
members who were part of that knew had
seen it so I wouldn't be surprised if
they did know but presumably they were
not supposed to have known those things
know so what's your take on Carter page
who really was at the center of that
which described how the federal
government spied on him based in part
anyway on allegations in the in the
dossier what do you think of him well
again I think the whole thing's a little
bit ridiculous I mean this is a
low-level person who worked in a
campaign this is someone who I've seen
the emails where they said well this
person's no longer working on the
campaign I believe one of my family
members responded who that heck is that
individual we've never even heard of
them so to use that again as the basis
to then try to attack the duly elected
president to do it then after that
person's no longer even part of a
campaign and now I've been on a campaign
I get it all of these people kind of
hang around and everyone wants to build
up their next thing because it means
they're gonna get a better job on the
next campaign they're gonna get their
book deal they want to be a part of
something the reality is he wasn't a
real player in the campaign so to
utilize that person I mean they seem
like a great patsy for that you know I'm
sure others were utilized the same way
but the reality of the situation is that
we've had an investigation going on for
over two years where there is zero
evidence we haven't seen any
investigations into all of the shade all
of the stuff that has gone on with our
opponent that were actual real things
that had happened that she was involved
in that transpired there's not even an
investigation but you can take a fringe
person on a campaign utilize that to get
all these fights on warrants to spy on
someone who'd alternately become the
president of the United States to
continue to do so based on evidence paid
by pay for by their political opponent
given and weaponized by the sitting
administration at the time I mean what
about this doesn't reek of a Banana
Republic car Tucker
its Crescent sound very American to me
dunt dunt rum thanks all for coming on
today every day